[Musik]
die folgende sendung wird vom neuen
super rewards weiter 4 x 4 präsentiert
[Musik]
der film fängt in der schweiz verhandelt
vormaliger und enttäuschungen aber auf
die heimatbasis heimat
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die anderthalb jahre sieben familien
mehr im iran ist gelüftet
dort haben dass neues leben angefangen
nennen sie es gar steuer teilweise
schweizer behinderten ihrer anders oder
beides es ist meine geschichte aber es
könnte genauso gut geschichte sicher vor
anderen menschen und schweiz gesehen und
displays liebesorte muss zurück
bis zu meiner wurzeln
meine lebensgeschichte also jetzt noch
schwierig und so nicht bleiben
[Musik]
mal dinge abstellen kann
familie ist familie ist sich für wichtig
familie
ich bin sehr familiär morgen irgendeine
sehr intakte familie verhältnis und der
fahrt gestorben ist dass wir zusammen
haben darum hat der stellenwert von der
familie für mich
der ist eine ganz liebe zwischen zwei
kulturen daher auch regen
das gespürt die anzieht das persische
kultur die scheu mehr der nicht mehr das
kino gebracht worden
[Musik]
und die hat es oft begleitet am times
square knapp 220 dass man bleibt die
sprachen ihm geredet wolle mit der
sprachsoftware bin mit der meist sehr
und einer duft und griff und jetzt bin
ich knapp 40 punkte spiel
[Musik]
bartoli
ok team haben nun schon seit märz das
position position oder weil ich merke
ist so ich schlafe das ist wirklich
erwägen nach wörter slowakei das in der
nächsten tage und wochen pausiert aber
es ist alles gut charlottes jetzt mit
papier fertig projekten werde mir den
teer an sich auch telefonate wo ist das
kitzeln
er hat stark im zeichen alter ist und
ich möchte nochmal ein stein vom herzen
ja das kommt alles neu und ich glaube
das wird ja auch mega spannend ist
allerdings erforderlich vielleicht
können wir dann am ziel deutschlands
wirklich so glatt ist jetzt unterwegs
steuert ziel und wie froh ich muss
einfach real weg über die grenze kommen
bislang und ich glaube dass gott ein
iraner wille zeiger ins auge
[Musik]
ich bin im mobilen internet geboren in
die model waren tommy haas lerin zerrt
handelsort mein vater der iran sparen
pure dem rasen studiert geborene scheer
im iran antwortete rechtsform er ist
1811 sie 1980 bricht erste golf lebens
unter beschuss was meine familie das
haus in teheran verlangt mehr frieren in
schweiz in kurven oft wachsen und kv
gemacht oben vater gestorben ist
in italiens xii
[Musik]
nicht mit hubraum auf co2 unterwegs
aber er versichert lernte sie vermögen
geschädigt sieht duisburg schweben tisch
immer wieder aus er stern.de
halte sich nick cannon regler gott sein
eigener weg muss ihr tier frage ich
selber machen
aber auch sehr viel richtig dass mit
sich
[Musik]
dann familie für geht es für euch
deswegen wird es sein das war damals das
mitteilung dass madoff fall will ich
meiner regierung sie vater hat ihn mir
vorgelebt wenn er mit der familie
kommuniziert hätte und das leben lebt da
sind ja total verdrängt und ist sie
eigenen weg gegangen
kommt ganz anders als die usa hat sich
anrufe wo sie die vierte glaubt weiss
jetzt aber ich glaube er meine sagte
verdi hat ja schon aber die während der
fahrt auf der welt geht
und das merkt dass wir anders sind als
normale klassische schweizer das ist mir
klar und das ist ein teil für warum
jetzt auch in sehr schöner moment spüre
die vorwürfe ich bin ich immer dass sie
in ihrer villa
blockbuster the taste of duty schaden in
der go s und basta politik zu gewinnen
[Musik]
daher kommt mittel in einer hütte
schönste nacht für die neid-elf lebens
von oxygen ich weiß noch wie wir das
nicht können verstehe den moment also an
diesem vormittag mit 220 und hab mir
sogar das ist für ihn wahnsinnig
schwierig sie es schlau und einfach
selber saßen leiber gewässerwart und ja
[Musik]
ihm ist es wichtig dass mit der idee
erkennen und wir sind ein schöner sieht
erkennen und kreuth wenn ihr jetzt auf
die reise
[Musik]
bevor es losgeht manassero wie in der
schweiz kennt plan zum gloria
bis 3
[Musik]
bayerischen letzten arbeitstag
einheimische alljährlicher klar ist das
ist vielleicht die prominent wird
verschiedene kategorien nominiert zu
werden und eine familie schätzen
abschluss ein großer reiz sein mal statt
jetzt wird man nervös sind
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja ich kaufe zu erzählen
doch so vieles vorbereitet aber der
letzte schliff ist nur zu machen
ja das geschehen aber die wir haben ist
jetzt also natürlich januar bis mitte
januar das hätte ganz viel schnee im
skigebiet und das ist das große ziel
jetzt habe ich kinder vom labor betreuen
im januar sehen dass man sehkraft
spiegeln ab macht sie zwei gepäckstücke
verkauft
das auto früheren rassismus rumänien
darf aber nicht mit dir die losfahren
mit der tageszentrum starten halb
grimmig no habe einen ganz groben
schnitzer der mensch mit so finster
jerry ist unglaublich
für die nach teheran sind fast 5000
kilometer acht länder reiste
mineralischer wurzel ein roadtrip mit
meinem freund und viel mehr machen
ohne ihn könnte das abend juni folgen
wenn sich straff
313 richtig cool und eigentlich richtig
hier abfahren
was ist unklar
hier momentan schritte
hartz iv
fragt sich nur
wie viel frau kuby beschäftigt und
beschäftigt die frage was überhaupt
wurde füle
[Musik]
wir treffen lebenslange fühlen denn von
ihrer mama
[Musik]
gestorben ist haben wir uns nicht
headley von ihnen hält vorhaben mitträgt
[Musik]
das telefon bei mir in england
die karte bitte bitte bitte bitte komm
ich brauche ich ganz dringend die sieben
hat sich verliebt in ein iraner und sie
werden heiraten ich nachts nicht einmal
18 ich glaube sie war selbst sein ich
glaube ja und ich kam natürlich hinüber
sie hat diese to machine is ausreden du
musst sagen sie kann den iran mit einer
und ich bin natürlich gefahren und ich
habe gesehen es ist alles umsonst
sie ist total verliebt hat musste
heiraten war mit ihr seien und dass ich
hab gewusst die serie gut gehen aber das
war ich will ein kind genau das was
eigentlich deine eltern wenn ich ganz
ehrlich bin nicht wollte alles getan was
die nicht wollten war das schon so früh
ich habe es in meiner erinnerung ich
weiß ich weiß in meiner erinnerung die
sie heute noch
ich verspreche dir jetzt dass ich nach
der reise zurückkommt
ja das mache ich danke schön
die mich in unserem frauen weg bleiben
das mache ich
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
mit dem august reiser das ist aber
daraus
und am anderen auto show
wenn der fahrer und so langsam sind
das eda habe dass ich ein schönes
braucht man viel zu wenig
[Musik]
die
von wetzstein wir setzen so wenig sie
das kleine fragezeichen
euro genannt
was ist
sie schlug
diese kraft ist selbst der nächste
in albanien
[Musik]
das heißt dass castro für das auge fast
alles
warten
[Musik]
german
ok
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
das bei den extrem gute stimmung
dass ich rot verloren hat kommt was
wasserspaß zum wasser gegeben
[Musik]
so sorgen dass sie die erste rede als ps
und dazu
also die kinder sind sehr persisch und
der schweiz
natürlich maschine in persischer projekt
als schweizer ist schon lustig obwohl
die schweiz zu sehen
wahrscheinlich denken sie könnten nach
dem krieg wieder zurück es ist eine
maxime wenn nicht in iran oder wenn ihr
das ist eben wie jetzt das ist aber ein
sehr altes kloster krise joachim
persisch obwohl sie als schweizerin
geboren worden ist
20 jahren schweiz falls entgangen ist
sehr interessant dass sie lebt ist das
auch sehr stark
[Musik]
[Applaus]
als ich gehört habe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der octavia dazwischen zwei geschädigten
für mich und meine familie
[Musik]
verbraucherkommission wenn die in der 10
immer wenn es möglichst schweizer farben
und möglich nämlich das extrem
vereinfacht sie
in schweden sind aber schwierig ist
das heißt ich kaufe banane marzipan
derzeit noch offen
das hat keiner szene
das ist jetzt das auf das macht die welt
[Musik]
so also jetzt und immer unterwegs willen
gerade weil seine partei also es sind
ein paar kilometer und dann sehen wir
dann vom saarland bis nach istanbul
werden da die erfahrung machen und
versuchen das ist ja wahnsinnig naja ich
bis dato das nach ankara hauptstadt von
der türkei
[Musik]
es war immer von europa nach asien
mit dem bosporus
symbolfoto
symbol von zwei kulturen vor einer welt
voller brot
zwei kulturen
[Musik]
wenn es geschafft und geschafft
fix und fertig also 2009 108 kilometern
in ankara
es ist ziemlich genau zwölf wir sehen
weißen es stunden unterwegs aber sich
gut
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ankara ist für mich wichtiger punkt der
bereits beim mini erträgen wie es ist
und november unter 80 schilder heiligen
krieg wirklich die ganze existenz sky
und sie sind denn nach der 40 stunden
mit dem bus fahren sie mit anderen fotos
wissen organisiert nach ankara co und da
ist flugzeug in jeans mein motor um im
farbton die haben das immer wieder
erzählt das muss eine horrorfahrt sie
sie in dem bus den flügen der wechsel
gemacht erfahrung meine alte technik
kann auch das wetter ist einfach man
muss jetzt flüchten
das ist jetzt der fall ist ein drum
schätzen dass noch mal wichtig es ist
mitternacht ein mann kann schlafen und
dann gehen wir eigentlich klaren die
andere richtig reisen jetzt wieder in
der iran aber dass wir mit symbolisch
oder
[Musik]
nominell drei eigentlich weiß dass sie
an wählern im iran leben das ist ein
sicherer weg wie scan roboter aus
schweizerinnen zeit nehmen wir jetzt mit
dem erklärt blieben aber sie ein dritter
erklärt sie neben hübner
ja das muss wahnsinnig sexy sehen das
sehr vermisst
die mordrate den vermissten
[Musik]
mehr fälle in ankara und fahren nach
erbsen
die letzte etappe vor mir an
[Musik]
und immer wieder begegnet major-sieger
zum tee
[Musik]
schokolade
600 km abdullah schwierig
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das allein aus
[Musik]
nein
fast fertig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nur ich jeden herzlichen dank danke
okay okay
aber das gute alte buch
die persische kultur aber fast
verschwunden
[Musik]
wer alles verändert dort hatte ich dann
auch distanziert verrückte weise saniert
und das ist ja
[Musik]
nur zum spaß sie deutsch sprechen ja
warten sie mal in deutschland waren sind
sie zurückgekommen
er ist ein jahr dass wir jetzt besser
die abstände aber weniger geld muss
nicht extra arbeit gehen
samstags montag kein leben ein leben das
ist etwa das war mir eine große freude
danke alles gute alles gute
sieht einen schönen tag
[Musik]
so
insoweit gewöhnt
[Musik]
der übergang in den anhänger das werden
wir dann schon die fahrer und das ist
verboten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
da es merklich heben noch halt
ministergattin
[Musik]
in dresden bereich mit grenze zum iran
wir werden nervös
[Musik]
passende papier
zwar reicht
leipzig
[Musik]
der ferrar mehr vorstellen wie das
mini-break sie muss sehen
[Musik]
weil wir eine absetzung glück nicht was
ihr allerdings ein extrem schreckhaft
naturell passt möglicher schreckhaft und
ich bin überzeugt das kommt von einer
bogenbrücke schlager hinterher daneben
ein gewisses picks im sektor zucht und
haltung macht und
das ist einfach wortwörtlich im markt
bei und schon hatte grund warum das
militär irgendwie erwähnen und findet
ein festakt mit waffen kämpfen
[Musik]
jetzt
die folge die letzte kriegs und dank
wenn wir normalform zeigen wir die
ganzen nach steuern bei minus 41 grad
master motor laufen die ganze nacht
motor laufen viel der schweiz nicht gern
noch ein anderes problem
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ein wechselfehler arbeitet müssen jetzt
nach spanien an der grenze gesetzt da
und es hat jetzt auf die polizei und
militär und später kam das ist jetzt
habe ich glaub schlafen würden jetzt
zugab und derweil das lied stimmten dazu
zwei jahre lang auf die reise
vorbereitet und versucht man alles zu
denken
ein papier unterschrieben trek stellt
gebühr bezahlt und müssen trotzdem nicht
bewiesen iran in not dafür haben zum
ersten mal officer der reis angst nicht
verkehrt wenn man gewusst hätten was sie
erwartet
[Musik]
mit laufbestzeit und zum setzte
importiere jegliche kosten sprechen
deswegen wir es mehrfach es ist das
arbeiten werden wird
schale was wird sein wenn sie neue plan
macht also wenn ich das auto ist
verabschiedet aber dem auto
und
mitfahren tag see und lorenz kann er
wenn er diese reise nicht aufgehen
aber es ist jetzt auf einmal alles
anders
dass selbst der letzte mieter in dem
haus verbringen und ehrlichkeit
aber das geht jetzt kosten und
zeitverlust und weniger fährt man sport
los um einen zweite bundesland
journalist ristretto es ist alles
geschafft wir können zwar in der iran
reisen nun aber dieses auto abgeben und
zwar für immer
wir sind wieder ein bisschen im iran
[Musik]
seht selbst schuld
ein flug aus
wir treten noch nie fertig und mit
soviel war meine kräfte meister - leider
die straßen ist setzte nicht unter druck
na das ist doch mal stress mit sieben
spielen stoppen
du hast einfach am ende nach
bis 6 juni fahren
[Musik]
wir fahren jetzt so
sondermaschinen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
also ist selbst in zweiter teil heute in
der woche machen wir das oft spuren im
iran zwei mal mit dem großvater im
wallis armbanduhr und eine frau handeln
santa cruz wo die früheste kindheit
verbracht haben und wer unter beschuss
eines opfers mehrere überwacht werden
wenn ich könnte dir dem nächsten flieger
gestiegen
[Musik]
diese sendung wurde vom neuen subaru
ward zweiliter firma 4 präsentiert
[Musik]